this is from Van Jones on CNN the police
who killed Tyree Nichols were black but
they might still have been driven by
racism it's just what he's the same one
at CNN he's the one that occasionally
you're like oh van Jones said something
I agree with you right occasionally
three decades ago when four white LA
police officers were videotaped beating
Rodney King the public outcry was heard
around the world in fact I got arrested
for the first time in my life during
protests that followed and I
subsequently dedicated my career as a
lawyer to helping to sue Rogue cops
closed prisons and reform the criminal
justice system
what happened to gang was horrifying he
then goes into mention but at least he
survived Tyree Nichols did not yada yada
five former Memphis police officers
fired for their elected actions during
Nichols versus a legend it was a video
of it have now been indicted I was in
law enforcement during the Rodney King
incidents as a chief by all accounts he
was good how do we explain Nichol's
horrific killing alleged the hands of
police who looked like him from the King
beating to the murder nearly three three
years ago of George Floyd blah blah blah
blah